[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
on the flight here
i was reminded about my mom i'm a
self-taught cellist i've never had a
lesson
i studied double bass but i just picked
up the cello and started playing because
i loved doing it
but my mom was an inspiration to me i
did not realize she was an inspiration
because she
got her music degree through a mail
order course the us school of music
while raising two kids she received a
lesson a week
in the mail and practiced and at the end
of a couple years
she put on a recital and uh i'll be 50
this month
and it took me that long to realize that
she was that big of an inspiration
and i'm just going to keep yeah thanks
mom
and she's also one of the most
extraordinary people i know beyond
uh being a wonderful musician i want to
play a little bit for mom
and your moms as well actually
[Music]
you know when you normally hear cell you
think of this
[Music]
we're not going to do that today
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you